MaMartine Biron, analyste
popolitique, Michel David,
chchroniqueur au journal
"L"Le Devoir" et Christian Dufo,
popolitologue, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - C'était une période de
ququestion qui m'a fait penser
auaux périodes de questions avec
MoMonsieur Bouchard ou parfois à
s's'enflammait à l'époque et on
fafaisait trois topos avec
plplusieurs versions.
C'C'était notre carburant. C'est
momoins comme ça mais cela été
inintéressante. Je vous fais
enentendre un premier extrait tt
dede suite. Madame Anglade attae
susur les 6 milliards de
gagarderies. En disant à Monsier
LeLegault : vous n'allez pas
lalaisser 6 milliards sur la
tatable. Pourquoi vous dîtes qul
fafaut voter pour Monsieur
O'O'Toole.
CÇa prend des places.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
PaParti libéral du Québec
- - Je ne pense pas qu'il est
enen train de nous dire qu'on ne
cocomprend pas les champs de
cocompétences. Ce on lui demande
papar contre, c'est de ne pas
memettre un genoux à terre pour.
paparce que les 6 milliards $,
jeje pense que c'est une très
bobonne entente pour les famills
dudu Québec.
- - Il y a trois partis qui
veveulent entrer dans les champs
dede compétence du Québec,
ququi ne veulent pas nous donner
lele pouvoir de protéger
lele français, qui ne veulent ps
nonous donner le pouvoir pour
prprotéger nos valeurs.
NoNous, on n'accepte pas ça.
SiSi le Parti libéral est prêt
àà se vendre au plus offrant,
bibien c'est le choix du Parti
lilibéral. Le leader de son par,
ilil a aidé Justin Trudeau à
prpréparer ses débats.
DoDonc, c'est qui est
lele vrai patron du leader?
- - Monsieur Fortin, député
lilibéral à Québec a aidé Monsir
TrTrudeau dans un groupe pour
prpréparer le dernier débat en
frfrançais. Martine, c'était toe
nonotre entrée en matière.
- - On est tout muscle à Québec,
frfrais et dispos.
- - Qu'est-ce que vous avez vu e
çaça.
- - Prêt pour l'année électoral,
çaça c'est certain.
C'C'est l'occasion pour les pars
d'd'opposition surtout de se
dédémarquer. Surtout qu'il y a
didifférentes positions. Ce sera
unune session garderie
prprobablement parce qu'elle vae
papasser beaucoup de choses. Ily
a a des milliards de dollars à
OtOttawa, c'est ententes entre
MoMonsieur Legault et Monsieur
TrTrudeau pour compléter
lele réseau des garderies.
MaMais également pour compensere
QuQuébec. Parce que le Québec et
dédéjà fort avancé, avec la
balance, si on n'a pas besoin au
QuQuébec de 6 milliards au compt
alalors Monsieur Legault pourrat
l'l'utiliser ailleurs.
LeLes partis d'opposition vont e
dédémarquer sur ce point en dist
: : Monsieur Legault, en prenant
popour les bleus, il n'a pas dit
leles conservateurs aujourd'hui,
ilil ne laisse sur la table cet
arargent si utile.
EnEn année électorale c'est
cecertain que tous les partis vt
vovouloir courtiser les famille,
c'c'est très important.
- - Il en a remis Monsieur
LeLegault. Il a dit : oui, oui,e
susuis bleu. Il y a les bleus et
onon est nationaliste.
MaMais il a dit au parti québécs
: : vous et moi, on est sollicié
àà défendre la nation du Québec.
IlIl en remet. Non seulement ile
rerecule pas, il en remet.
- - Oui, il en remet mais je pee
ququ'il va très bien ce qui estn
trtrain de se dessiner c'est-à-
didire que lui envoient les
sosondages, plus la perspective
d'd'un gouvernement libéral
miminoritaire, probablement avec
l'l'appui du NPD, c'est le pire
scscénario pour Monsieur Legaul.
AlAlors on sent que ça l'inquiè.
MaMais ce qui m'a frappé le plus
pependant cette période de
ququestions, on a abordé bien sr
dedes dossiers québécois :
leles places en garderie, les
tetests rapides le troisième
liliern, mais en arrière fond iy
avavait toujours la campagne
féfédérale et à chaque fois on y
rerevenait d'une manière ou d'ue
auautre. On a vu l'échange avec
MoMonsieur Legault qui dit
quque les libéraux sont prêts à
vevendre leur âme pour 6
mimilliards. Les libéraux disent
quque Legault s'agenouille devat
leles conservateurs. À chaque
fofois, on finissait par revenià
lala campagne fédérale.
EtEt moi je prévois que bien au-
dedelà de l'élection, la relatin
quque les partis au Québec
vovont avoir avec l'éventuel fur
gogouvernement, qu'il soit pouru
cocontre, va teinter beaucoup la
prprochaine année. Évidemment il
vava y avoir des dossiers
prproprement québécois, mais les
rerelation fédérale-provinciale
vovont prendre une place assez
grgrande.
- - Christian, qu'avez-vous pené
dede cette période?
- - Je trouve que Monsieur Legat
pepersiste et signe, comme vouss
l'l'avez dit, c'est très clair.
C'C'est dans le dossier de la
dédéfense du pouvoir québécois t
ilil a raison sur ce dossier
spspécifique de dire que les
coconservateurs historiquement
ininterviennent beaucoup de moys
dadans les compétences
prprovinciales que les libéraux.
IlIl prend un risque.
AuAudacieux, la prise de positin
ququ'il a adoptée et je trouve
ququ'au Québec on est plus dans
l'l'audace et le risque.
CeCe n'est pas étonnant que ça é
chchoqué beaucoup de monde. Au
fofond, comme Michel le dit, si
leles libéraux sont élus
miminoritaires et rien et fais
enencore, mais ils sont élus
miminoritaires ça ne durent pas
tetellement bien pour la relatin
dede Monsieur Legault avec les
lilibéraux mais pour les gardere
seses gagnants. Si les libéraux
l'l'emportent et ne désirant pas
l'l'intention des garderies pare
quque Monsieur Legault...
- - le Civilia est dans la poch.
- - Il est dans la poche.
EtEt Monsieur Legault a réussi
ququelque chose. La lettre que .
O'O'Toole a envoyée à Monsieur
LeLegault c'est inédit.
LeLes paroles s'envolent, les
écécrits restent. La lettre qu's
onont publiée, M. O'Toole savoir
ququand même pas mal.
QuQuand va se rencontrer dans le
prpremier jour. On reconnaît que
lele système québécois est
didifférent. Je trouve que
MoMonsieur Legault a plus à gagr
ququelque chose que prévu.
C'C'est clair qu'il risqué on et
papas habituer à ça.
- - Mais ça ne vous étonne pas?
PaParce que je vais vous faire
enentendre un autre extrait
ouou en répondant parti québécos
ququi dit qu'ils n'ont rien obtu
dudu fédéral. Il dit : attentio.
EtEt là, rappelez-vous, il vient
dede dire que les rouges ne
rerespectent pas, on a rien été
didifficile. Mais elle fait la
liliste de tout ce qu'il a obteu
- - On a eu 1,8 milliard pour
lele logement sans condition.
OnOn a eu 6 milliards sans
cocondition pour les services
dede garde. On a eu quatre
enententes sur la formation
dede la main-d'oeuvre. On a eu
60600 millions en aéronautique.
OnOn a eu 460 millions, Internet
hahaute vitesse. 374 millions
popour les demandeurs d'asile.
OnOn a réglé la gestion de
l'l'offre. On a fait une lutte
àà l'itinérance, on a obtenu
17172 millions. On a obtenu
3 3 milliards pour la relance
sésécuritaire sans condition.
- - Martine!
IlIl vient de dire qu'avec Trudu
ilil n'a rien, ce n'est pas
popossible. Il respecte pas la
nanation québécoise. Il fait la
liliste de tout ce qu'il a reçu.
- - Je n'ai noté moi aussi. Il a
unun paradoxe dans ce qu'il dit.
C'C'est vrai que Monsieur Trudeu
prpropose d'imposer des normes n
sasanté etc. mais dans sa liste,
didit très souvent que c'est sas
cocondition. Alors il est
nénégociable, Monsieur Trudeau,à
cecertains égards. C'est vrai
ququ'il y a un paradoxe dans
l'l'ensemble.
- - Tour de table là-dessus.
CÇa vous a frappé Michel.
QuQuand il a fait sa liste au PQ
çaça ne vous a pas frappé avec e
ququ'il avait dit juste avant?
- - On se disait : pourquoi il e
rerecommande pas Monsieur Trudeu
àà ce compte? Mais je pense que
MoMonsieur Trudeau étend même
cocomptable. Si on élargit le
poportrait, les 6 % je comprends
quque ce n'est pas ce que
dedemandent les provinces 6 %
d'd'augmentation par que M.
O'O'Toole est prêt à consentir x
prprovinces, si on met ça sur ue
pépériode le moindre langue, c't
plplus que ce que Monsieur Legat
a a énuméré. Et si on ajoute
leles 4 milliards présumé mort s
coconservateurs accepteraient de
papayer pour le troisième lien,
auau total c'est pas mal plus qe
cece que Monsieur Trudeau a pu
coconsentir au cours des deux ou
trtrois dernières années.
EtEt on le sait, ce qu'on a eu a
nene compte plus. C'est ce qu'on
auaura après qui compte.
CeCeci étant dit c'était assez
bibizarre d'entendre Monsieur
LeLegault faire cette énumérati.
- - Dans la même question.
ChChristian.
- - Moi, je suis moins étonné qe
vovous. De ça. Parce que c'est
sasans condition qui est
imimportant. Tout ce qu'il a
obobtenu sans condition, je
cocomprends qu'il s'en vante trs
bibien. Mais le gouvernement de
MoMonsieur Trudeau envoie un
memessage très clair à l'effet
ququ'il va intervenir dans les
chchamps de compétences
prprovinciaux. Le message est
clclair comme de l'eau de roche.
C'C'est une autre game,.
- - On recommence une partie.
- - Monsieur Legault ce qu'il a
obobtenu tout ça et pourquoi ile
s's'en vendrait pas. Mais dans e
dodomaine de la santé Monsieur
TrTrudeau l'a dit et redit :
ilil va y avoir des conditions.
MoMonsieur Legault se positionne
vrvraiment sur l'axe...
momoi je serais très mal à l'aie
papar rapport à son intervention
popour être franc. Dans un syste
féfédéral ces deux niveaux de
cocompétences. Normalement on
emembarque pas dans le terril de
l'l'autre. Monsieur Legault
emembarque sur le thème de
rerespecter les compétenences.Çe
dédéfend beaucoup plus que bien
dedes gens le disent.
- - Très bien.
MoMonsieur Trudeau, si jamais il
reremporte une minorité lundi,
jeje recommence avec vous
ChChristian, tour de table rapi.
QuQuel genre de relation
etet de rapport de force on va
avavoir avec Monsieur Legault àe
momoment?
- - Écoutez, rappelons que pour
leles garderies, on va voir les6
mimilliards, ça c'est clair.. Il
fafaut le dire. Quand même.
PoPour le reste dans le domainee
lala santé c'est clair que les
rerelations ne seront pas d'amor
tetendre, si vous voulez,
mamais ils sont tellement en
opopposition. Sur les dossiers
ididentitaires élucidés plus en
opopposition. Quand on a brûlé s
lilivres Canada Monsieur n'a pas
étété capable de dénoncer.
MoMonsieur Legault a dit que
c'c'était atroce.
DaDans le domaine de la santé
MoMonsieur Trudeau veut imposer
dedes conditions. Les relationse
seseront pas très bonnes mais is
seseront obligés de fonctionner.
EtEt pour poursuivre mon
arargumentaire de tantôt, dossir
dede respect des compétence du
QuQuébec est beaucoup dans l'are
popolitique. On en parle et on n
rereparle. Personnellement je ss
cocontent de ça.
- - Et est-ce que, Michel David,
MoMonsieur Legault ne veut pas
plplacer Madame Anglade en
cocontradiction et le parti
lilibéral du Québec et du Canada
etet des champs de compétences.
EsEst-ce qu'il ne place pas
fifinalement il ne met pas la
tatable pour sa campagne à lui?
- - Tout à fait.
MaMais Madame Anglade est tout à
fafait consciente qu'il faut
ququ'elle se situe sur un regise
bebeaucoup plus nationaliste que
lala Parti libéral les années
dedernières. Mais dans une
susurenchère de nationalisme, ne
popourra jamais suivre Monsieur
LeLegault. Ça c'est certain.
AÀ un moment donné elle va
frfrapper le mur. Mais pour
rerevenir à la question que vous
poposez à Christian, les relatis
enentre les deux, ça risque d'êe
didifficile. Je regardais
l'l'extrapolation de siège que
PhPhilippe Fournier faisait
tatantôt, si on additionne les..
jeje pense que c'était 146 pour
leles libéraux. Mais 32
nénéodémocrates. Alors Monsieur
TrTrudeau va pouvoir s'appuyer
susur le NPD pour faire avancer
soson programme centralisateur.
EtEt aussi son programme, commet
didire, multiculturaliste.
AlAlors ce n'est pas une bonne
nonouvelle alors qu'inversement,
mmême si les conservateurs
avavaient les sièges extrapolés
MoMonsieur Fournier et qu'on
ajajoutait ceux du Bloc,
ilil n'arrive pas à la majorité.
AlAlors ça risque d'être assez
ininconfortable pour Monsieur
LeLegault.
- - Il en manque pas beaucoup ms
ilil en manque un peu. Il en
mamanque comme cadre. Un petit t
llà-dessus Martine.
- - Ça va quand même être plus
fafacile il est minoritaire que
s's'il est majoritaire. Mais por
rerebondir ce que Michel disaitn
pepeu plus tôt, quelque soit le
rérésultat de lundi prochain, ça
vava avoir un impact sur les
dédébats à Québec. Les relations
QuQuébec-Ottawa vont s'inviter
popour la prochaine session
cocomplètement. Et déjà,
lele parti québécois a commencéà
poposer des questions sur les
coconvictions profondes de
MoMonsieur Legault. Qu'est-ce
ququ'il intention de faire...
- - allez-vous redevenir
sosouverainiste bientôt?
- - C'est la question qui va se
poposer quelque soit le résulta.
- - Ça vous fait sourire
ChChristian.
- - Ça m'étonnerait qu'il deviee
sosouverainiste maisis il est
frfranchement nationaliste.
CÇa rappelle de vieux souvenirs.
CeCela dit pour Madame Anglade
trtrouve que c'est une catastroe
lala nouvelle Kassand leader
paparlementaire et participer àa
prpréparation du débat de Monsir
TrTrudeau.
- - Monsieur Fortin.
- - Et il a dit qu'il
ininterviendrait dans les
cocompétences provinciales. Sa
mimine la crédibilité du parti
lilibéral pour les défenseurs...
- - Là-dessus Michel se rendrait
FoFortin est-ce que c'était une
ererreur pour lui d'aller donner
ceces services à l'équipe de
MoMonsieur Trudeau?
- - C'est une récidive. Il avait
fafait la même chose en 2019.
SoSouvenez-vous, au printemps tt
lele monde se demandait s'il
alallait se présenter au fédéral
ouou s'il allait rester au niveu
ququébécois. Honnêtement,
popour moi ce n'est pas une
susurprise. C'est une gaffe, je
susuis d'accord. Ça paraît malÇa
cocontredit le discours de sa
chcheffe. Mais Monsieur Fortin,
elelle fait parti de l'aile la
plplus fédéraliste du caucus
lilibéral à Québec.
AlAlors je ne suis pas surpris e
ceces convictions s'expriment
cocomme ça. Mais dans les
cicirconstances, c'est évident e
c'c'est une bourde.
- - Moi aussi je pense que c'est
unune erreur et d'ailleurs ça
rérépond, sans il en parce qu'il
s's'est enfargé, il dit :
n'n'importe quel chef qui demane
memes services je lui aurais doé
memes services. J'aurais mal vu
avavec d'autres chefs. Il était
prpris dans les câbles et essayr
dede se dépatouiller.
LuLui qui répond habituellement
bibien en question.
- - Le PLQ ne veut pas devenir a
susuccursale du PLC.
- - Surtout quand ils essaient e
sese distancie d'Ottawa.
- - Sur la question des
cocompétences.
- - Monsieur Legault était
papassablement batailleur là-
dedessus.
- - On a l'extrait. J'avais
sosorti... on va sortir les
exextraits. On va réentendre por
ceceux qui ont manqué le début e
l'l'émission.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
- - Qui est le vrai patron. Este
ququ'il a dit à Justin Trudeau
ququ'on voulait protéger le
frfrançais, protéger nos valeur?
- - Monsieur le président vous
auaurait remarqué qu'au-dessus e
vuvue il n'y a plus de croix, ps
dede crucifix, qui a quitté le
sasalon bleu. On n'a pas besoin
d'd'avoir un premier ministre qi
jojoue un rôle de curé comme en
191950,00 euros comment penser r
ququi voter, Monsieur le
prprésident.
- - Avait conseillé n'importe ql
chchef de parti. Ça été le cas n
202019 2021
(r(rires)
- - dans les deux cas c'est
totoujours le même.
- - Crucifix!
- - Qui est parti.
OnOn ne va pas relancer ce déba.
MaMais c'est intéressant. C'état
unune période de questions
inintéressant pour ceux que ça
inintéresse. Garderie je vais y
rerevenir. On va écouter M.
O'O'Toole parce qu'on n'en a paé
rarapidement. Il a écrit une
lelettre au premier ministre du
QuQuébec. Je vais être par la pr
leles cinq premiers jours, il a
didit. Mais dans son cadre
fifinancier il ne peut pas sauvr
lala chèvre et le chou. Des
crcrédits d'impôt il était en
avavec une partie de l'argent qe
leles libéraux enverraient en
prprovince. On écoute M. O'Toole
etet Monsieur Blanchet
c c 24 s.
ERERIN O'TOOLE, chef,
PaParti conservateur du Canada
- - Je vais coordonner avec
lele premier ministre Legault
etet j'ai un budget dans
nonotre plateforme chiffrée
etet j'ai envoyé une lettre hier
auau premier ministre Legault
paparce que c'est très important
popour moi d'avoir une approche
dede respect pour le système
auau Québec. Et on va collaborer
etet coordonner avec le plan
auau Québec et notre plan.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET, chef,Q
- - Avez-vous vu quelque chose
dede nouveau dans sa lettre?
ExExactement la même affaire
ququ'il dit depuis le début.
CÇa reste Erin O'Toole, ça reste
leles conservateurs, ça reste
dedes valeurs qui vont pas dans
lele sens de celles du Québec.
MaMais on dirait que les positis
dedes conservateurs bougent au é
dedes sondages. Je vais donner
unun conseil amical à M. O'Tool:
fifiez-vous pas trop
susur les sondages.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU, chef, PLC
- - Si les Québécois sont
prpréoccupés, comme je sais
ququ'ils le sont, par M. O'Toole
pupuis son plan de ramener en
ararrière, c'est pas le Bloc qui
pepeut empêcher un gouvernement
coconservateur. On a besoin que
leles Québécois progressistes
chchoisissent un gouvernement
prprogressiste. Plein de Québécs
prprêts à lutter pour leurs
prpriorités à tous les jours,
etet c'est ce que nous sommes.
- - L'appelle au vote progressie
ququi va commencer, ça va
s's'amplifier au cours des
prprochains jours de la part des
lilibéraux. Tour de table. La
ququestion des garderies néanmos
emembête M. O'Toole depuis le
dédébut avec l'électorat
ququébécois. Christian,
cece n'est pas chiffré, ce n'est
papas clair.
- - Remarquez, Monsieur Blanchet
fafait peut-être son travail mix
quque mon mémoire en Lizzan la
lelettre j'ai appris des choses.
D'D'abord c'est une lettre. C'et
écécrit. C'est assez rare comme
enengagement. Il dit
spspécifiquement qu'on reconnaît
quque le système du Québec est
didifférent. Cela dit il y a un
ririsque. Ça ne veut pas dire
CoCofield arrivée le Québec va
avavoir 6 milliards.
MaMais j'ai appris quelque chose
quque je ne savais pas, Monsieur
O'O'Toole s'est avancé. Il faut
didire que la montée substantiee
dudu bloc semble avant tout numo
coconservateur au Québec.
AlAlors il y a une espèce de
cocompétition.
- - Le débat anglais a eu plus
d'd'effet que Monsieur Legault.e
pepense qu'on peut dire ça.
- - C'est très juste.
- - Ça c'est très clair. Le bloa
étété galvanisé par le dérapage
dudu débat en anglais. C'est
clclair. Maintenant, si ça ne
s's'était pas produit, peut-être
quque la pluie de Monsieur Legat
auaurait eu un effet positif por
leles conservateurs mais
clclairement, c'est plus
ququ'annulé. Maintenant pour les
gagarderies, je suis assez
d'd'accord avec Monsieur Blanch.
SoSouvenez-vous lors du débat qe
vovous animez, Patrice, les
coconservateurs disaient :
mamais on est prêt à collaborer
avavec le Québec. Il y avait déà
unune ouverture. Mais l'ouvertue
nene peut pas être tellement
grgrande. D'après ce que je
cocomprends ce serais simplement
popour la première année.
LaLa semaine dernière on parlait
d'd'un chèque de 660 millions.
OnOn est loin, loin des 6
mimilliards.
- - Les chiffres la tête dure.
DaDans son cadre financier on vt
quque l'économie qu'il fait
sisi toutes les ententes que
TrTrudeau a signées avec les
prprovinces. On les enlève. On e
pepeut pas les enlever et les
reremettre en même temps.
- - Il reste 1,2 milliards pour
totout le monde.
- - Exactement, pour la première
anannée pour compenser. Martine.
- - Bien, Monsieur n'a pas dit n
momot de cette lettre aujourd'h.
AlAlors visiblement, ça avait
momoyennement d'importance pour
lului. Ce qu'il y avait dans la
lelettre, on le savait au
lelendemain du débat.
MoMonsieur O'Toole, s'il avait
vovoulu marquer le coup sur cete
ququestion, ça aurait été
d'd'envoyer sa lettre dès le
lelendemain du débat.
IlIl me semble que ça vient tard
dadans le débat alors que la
ququestion a déjà été soulevée.
DDès le lendemain des partis
d'd'opposition parlait du 6
mimilliards de Monsieur Trudeau
veversus 1,7 milliards de Monsir
O'O'Toole.
- - Le fond, Michel a dit tout à
l'l'heure, c'est que Monsieur
LeLegault, il aime mieux mais
MoMonsieur O'Toole où il n'y a s
dede conditions en santé ou
aiailleurs quitte à perdre un pu
d'd'argent. Et grappiller des
chchoses à droite à gauche.
- - Tout est là.
OuOui excuser.
- - Oui mais c'est pour cette
raraison que Québec on parle tat
dedes garderies parce que les
lelecteurs à Québec et la.
IlIl est dans les familles.
L'L'enjeu des garderies à Québec
vava être très important.
IlIl y a des parents qui n'ont s
dede place. Il y a des
nénégociations aussi...
- - à court terme oui.
- - Avec le conseil du trésor et
leles éducatrices qui demandent2
%.%. Pardon. Le gouvernement ofe
1212 % de rattttrapage salarials
édéducatrices demandent 27 %.
ElElles ont des mandats de grèv.
CeCes bougies étaient-ils sur le
frfront, il y a plusieurs...
- - Conclusion.
- - Patrice je trouve que vous
avaviez bien résumé l'enjeu et e
trtrouve ça très sain dans le
dédébat public au-delà des
rérésultats, qui sont très
didifficiles à prévoir.
OnOn dit au québécois : il y a
l'l'argent, le cash il y a les
popouvoirs.
- - C'est cela.
- - Il y a un choix à faire.
- - Mais pour les parents qui et
auaussi l'électorat de Monsieur
LeLegault. Il y a les places.
- - Je ne nie pas ça mais au
niniveau macro politique, c'estn
dédébat fondamental qui est sain
momois je prétends que...
onon s'était beaucoup exploité r
lele plan de l'identité de façon
hohonteuse et en effet acheter t
çaça revient. On veut les 6
mimilliards mais...
- - En conclusion Michel.
- - Strictement sur le plan de
l'l'argent, Monsieur O'Toole ofe
plplus au total et à terme que
MoMonsieur Trudeau, malgré les
gagarderies. D'autre part,
MoMonsieur Legault veut se
prprésenter à la prochaine
élélection en disant : regarder
momoi j'ai un plan, un projet
auautonomiste est fa